hello my name is Liv Roush I'm the
producer and star of the upcoming movie
wrong
if you don't come see our movie I'm
gonna release
Kevin Smith
and nobody wants that he's gonna talk
cry and never shut up so please do us
all a favor watch wrong reasons for the
right reasons to shut Kevin Smith
no one
hey what's up this is
[Music]
[Music]
we've received word that a Los
angeles-based musician has been
kidnapped victim's name is Kat Odin
she's an Australian musician
detective Dobson right yes sir I might
see you earlier than this if you can't
solve this crime before some jack off on
the internet does then you can kiss your
job goodbye
oh man what are you people doing here
I'm not going on the record today we're
joined via satellite by Andrea and Jack
Odom I am not saying we should not
listen to her side of the story there's
still no word from the abductor from the
abductee from no one
[Music]
together
okay
another time
[Music]
[Music]
rejected
[Music]
[Music]
all right I'll let you say one thing
clerks three now on home video [ __ ] you